foreign
the streets are no joke I don't wish it
on people I I've seen things that other
people shouldn't never seen in their
life
I was mad at God and so I would curse
them out and why why aren't you helping
me I believe that my sister was sent by
him to save me you know say she's like
my guardian angel
oh
[Music]
I see uh changed
as
sometimes within the almost three years
trying to help out each other but some
people are better than
you know others are doing that God I
just can't like my I can't stand still
on my eyelids I can't even open I'm
skinny I'm going like this
my name is Jacqueline Hernandez and I am
Tyson's half-sister so we grew up
um apart he lived with his mom and my
dad and then I lived with my mom my
mom's side of the family are all
Christians they're all sober and
everybody kind of stayed together no
dysfunction and my dad's side was the
opposite it was all dysfunctional
alcoholics drug addicts my mom kept me
away from that she ended up leaving him
so that I would be raised differently
first time I got addicted to drugs I was
like
15 started smoking pot it gradually
moved to Oxycontin and I was a star
basketball baseball player just went on
a dowel room spiral very quickly
and then age 17
I got introduced to heroin and the
needle took me
I was stubborn and didn't didn't think I
had a problem I thought I could hide it
and I hit it pretty good for some time
until I started getting track marks I
still have you know
track marks up up and down my body you
know he lost contact probably when my
son was first born was when he first
really got into the smoking heroin and
shooting up
13 years of you know homelessness you
know living underneath cardboard boxes
bridges on the ground
uh boosted and stuff from stores just to
just doing whatever I could just to
survive when I when I learned I could
Panhandle I could make 250 to 300 bucks
a day and it could be an hour or it
could be in a couple hours people that
go to work you know a nine to five job
I'm making just more money than they are
and I only have to work two to three
hours when I would get money I was like
man this is so easy why didn't I do this
a long time ago what did you do
oh straight to the drug house or and I
would just go right up the hill and boom
there's fentanyl there's fentanyl powder
there's meth there's whatever you want
just right there
like I've seen people that's been out
there probably for over 20 years and to
watch their health and decrease watch
their body get full of MRSA it's just a
horrible lonely
I was depressed I selling drugs and
seeing the people like overdose right in
front of me that I sold them the drugs
and they over and I had to save them
shoot them up with Narcan
how many overdoses would you estimate
you've witnessed over a hundred
yep
I want to say about 20 of them
I was just like okay God help me help
him I was telling my neighbor and he was
a recovering addict from off the street
and he gave me Mike kersey's number
which is a guy who helps people get into
detox and as soon as I called Mike the
bar the ball started rolling first time
I found my brother again he was standing
up there by the tree with a shopping
cart and I pulled in up there
I was 115 pounds
and within 30 days I've already gained
60 pounds like I was a walking Skillet I
used to have to wear like
four or five hoodies you know just and I
didn't know I was that skinny when I
seen the the video of me like I can't
stay still it was shocking that I was
like that and I didn't think anything
was wrong with me here he goes everybody
thought God just worked miracles from
Miracle after Miracle the last month to
help him get into the detox to get into
Holmen and then from Holmen to his
housing don't give up on your loved ones
don't give up keep praying for them and
go out reach out to them don't enable
them by by giving them money or anything
like that just if you can maybe get them
some food and give them positive talk
let them know that you're still there
for them for an outlet if they want to
get help and don't give up on them
because if my brother can do it anybody
can and that's the truth right there
it's amazing how your body can heal so
quick I have a smile on my face
everywhere I go now
true it's over bro we can do it too
you just gotta get desperate for
Recovery yeah they gotta want to get
help you can't help yourself you know
you got to do it on your own you like
you know you got to put in effort or
you're not gonna make it
I want to have kids and have my own
house and a car you know and all the all
the normal things be a productive member
of society love you too
family is has power no matter how bad
your drug addiction is you can get
through it if I could then and I know
you guys can and I hope whoever sees
this video you know could change your
life because
if you just take it one day at a time
and
put positive
things out there positive things are
going to come it might not be right away
it could take some time just just do it
one day at a time
foreign